fine all the first derivative and you
like the first derivative I didn't know
there were any others and it's okay but
now but in your headings later this
would be useful to you because we will
distinguish between the first one and
other ones that you might work out so
the first we bought the derivative okay
you remember what the derivative is
another name for it where it started off
with was rise over run that's what first
principles is okay so we call this the
gradient function
so therefore if what we're really doing
then is the sign of the gradient
function okay another way of saying that
is the derivative tells you about the
grade or whether it's positive or
negative
okay so we say if the if the derivative
was called do I on the X okay if it's
positive that means the graph is
increasing it's going up
ok and close firstly if the derivative
the first derivative the gradient
function if it were negative then the
graph is decreasing it's going down so
let's do a really quick example write y
equals x quit you guys know what this
looks like
okay so when you take the first
derivative or third derivative you just
get 2x all right so when you think about
2x and what this looks like okay let's
just graph 2x
okay now what does the derivative and
the sign of the derivative specifically
what does it tell us about the graph
well at at X is less than zero right the
derivative is negative you can see there
the derivative is below the axis so that
means all of these days over here a
negative so that means the graph is
decreasing it's dropping which
corresponds to the fact that the
left-hand side of the parabola is doing
that shape going from afar to lower and
of course there after you pass the
origin the Duty becomes positive so it
turns around and here it's increasing
okay so it's pretty simple stuff right
I'm you might have remembered I
introduced a new word a few lessons ago
which was really long monotonically
monotonically which basically just means
always okay so when we say something is
a function is monotonically increasing
for instance okay for instance let's
think about why people say 5x okay
monotonically increasing I know it's
monotonically decreasing because when I
take the first derivative okay it's just
going to be five right because you're
taking that the power goes down and so
on okay this is really 5 X to the zero
okay so this number here the gradient
function is always positive any value of
x you put into it it just stays at five
okay so this is monotonically increasing
okay and the reason is because I don't
know if you knew this by the way you
know how therefore right there's three
dots it looks like that so you've got
like a therefore B you can actually say
it upside down look for a common but a
therefore B is the same as B because of
a oh so you're mine pudding right it's
upside down I just yeah I just mind
money for the rest of the day so you can
continue your brains monotonically
increasing because because demand the X
is greater than zero and is the
important bit right for all real values
of X you see that any value of x du by
DX will always be positive okay you need
to know that because sometimes I'll say
prove that such and such is
monotonically decreasing come in